the rich tapestry of the pc gaming
community modders are one of the most
inspiring subcultures in fact some of
the most popular genres today started as
pc gaming mods right now modders sean
fmp1 snelling and corey lado are making
something incredibly special in the form
of an ambitious mod for half-life alex
it's called levitation it's an original
four to five hour campaign that builds
on valve's original vr game half-life
alex with alex searching for a pair of
rebels gone rogue they've discovered a
strange floating building in sector x
and decided to investigate it against
orders obviously and now it's your turn
let's go back to the world of gordon
g-man and alex with this exclusive
gameplay footage
alex according to this old resistance
map there's a control room somewhere
outside the building you're in
sorry if that's vague the map was drawn
using somebody's blood
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alex i'm detecting an incredibly large
energy signature up ahead
it's probably gordon freeman and not
anything bad at all
definitely uh definitely probably gordon
freeman
[Music]
okay so the plan is to get to that
control room and get going
oh boy
are you
getting kind of crowded down here ross
[Music]
you seeing that
[Music]
[Music]
oh crap moving moving
[Music]
[Music]
so
good
oh
oh
nice
steady
[Music]
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
um
um
yourself left
oh boy
you